bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono vari j
oggi andiamo avanti su cat mario 4 ora
che nello scorso episodio mi ero fermato
qua siamo in paradiso non so dove stiamo
lì preciso perfetto ora è risaputo che
salire qui sopra non serve una beata
mazza andiamo giù perché non muoia
perché non vogliamo che non muoia perché
non voglio ragazzi ve lo giuro che diste
nuvole io prima o poi faccio un massacro
si infatti adesso non ci riuscirò mai
più ad arrivare lì è risaputo che io se
muoio una volta non li faccio più ok già
posso fare io posso fare non lo fo tifa
vj nuvole dei miei [ __ ] ragazzi ve
lo sto ricordando all'ultimo secondo che
c'era una nuvola lì è stato un miracolo
adesso non mi ricordo sono vivo sono
vivo siamo vivo tranquille adesso no
perché io quando vogliono mi ricordo
cosa c'è prima ok allora adesso ci siamo
devo andare a sinistra quando scendo a
sinistra a sinistra non raga seriamente
aspettatevi venuto un colpo di genio ed
è un miracolo quando succede soprattutto
a me aspettate aspettate no non vogliamo
il culo sorpreso con l'edizione mai mai
bene vai sì ce l'ha fatta lo sapevo lo
sapevo
era un altro il castello maledetti non
era quello ma che cosa che sapevo io
ragano mi chiede poi come ho fatto non
ne ho la più pallida idea
ci siamo finalmente stiamo penso
all'ultimo livello bat of adventure
ma the fat fabi j
l'epico ritorno alle psi soggetto mario
cos'è cos'è cos'è un gatto missile ogni
avvio cos'è chiusa in passato un gatto
cos'era quella roba ragazzi è passato
cos'è cos'è cos'è cos'è cos'è
raga io di gatti ne ho abbastanza anche
di quelli che sembrano dei toast oh mio
dio è un linguaggio ne frega non ce la
possiamo fare pieno di gatti e pieno di
botte
a mio avviso due fantasmi nun allora ce
la possiamo fare dobbiamo andare di
sopra perfetto ragazzi sono come faccio
andar qua sopra adesso ok ci sono dei
funghi
ci sono dei funghi nascosti che non so
se servono a qualcosa ed evo devo salire
questa droga come caccia faccia devo
premere questo no come si fa
ragazzi c'è un qualcosa di nascosto qui
rega mi sa che devo prendere uno di sti
due ma ci scommetto quello che volete
che uno dei due è sbagliato di sicuro
non so
premo a caso che culo l'altro e non so
che cos'è non lo voglio sapere
ma qualcosa di sbagliato di sicuro
dicevo che una sensazione incredibile
quando credete di fare un qualcosa di
giusto e poi è sbagliato come cazzo
fatto schivarlo non lo so non ne ho idea
ma ci ha avuto un culo assurdo stavolta
un cul incredibile ok che cos'è un mio
dio cioè un anno dall'inizio no
raga come cazzo si fa è impossibile
oddio dicono grande elio grande aiuto
sì sì sì come che hanno fatto che meglio
quando risolvi qualcosa senza
effettivamente fare una mazza è finta
sta roba probabilmente devo andare
avanti
ok ok io ci ho paura perchè tanto lo so
che prima o poi non c'è il gradino lo so
ok ok ok ragazzi ce la posso fare
va bene allora dico salto di cos'altro
di cossato sì sì sì no no no sì sì no
kat
l'onta prova
ma stiamo scherzando ma va all'asta
bandiera se ne deve andare a quel paese
prima cosa
seconda cosa
pato fa da jenson
[Musica]
che cazzo salti sentite e io non posso
farmi rovinare fegato da una bandiera e
cioè chiariamoci come diavolo dovrei
fare maledizione cedevo fotter l'affare
così suo classica zucca ok allora
abbiamo preso la bandiera ci siamo
quindi possiamo andare tranquilli
sì spero che allora qua già era morto
prima io deficiente ci sono ri morto
però va bene mi fa tanto sulla bandiera
allora titolo devo scrivere per forza se
vecchia pranzi a papera che cerco di
farlo seriamente alla notizia ma porca
[ __ ] a raga io non so se mi stanno
prendendo per il culo
non lo so ma ho dei presentimenti
comunque va beh ci siamo ci siamo
stronzo dovrei avercela fatta dovrei
dovrei un'altra bandiera vi prego cosa è
quello ragazzi devo prenderlo no non lo
so perché la presa o fantasmino quindi
non mi fido però devo prenderla perché
non mi pare ci siano altre vie
ma che cazzo sta succedendo perché c'era
un vecchio detto mario che senso ha
tutto questo c'è ma che cazzo va bene è
la prossima volta
hamsik lo fate fare a vostra sorella ok
perché non voglio più saperne
ma edizione allora passiamo a sto punto
cos'è
mi stavo attaccando live set benissimo
cos'è successo
oltre a passa adesso dare finalmente un
3 passo anche i muri rack e incredibile
va bene andiamo avanti così
c'è cos'è cos'è un mio dio apre
tematizzata quindi obbligati a [ __ ]
raga cosa devo fare cosa devo fare aiuto
aiuto
sì sì sì sì ok era più semplice di
quanto pensassi va bene così si è chiuso
non mi chiamo dio
no no no no no ora stavolta ho capito
dovrei riuscirci ok adesso saltare qui
sopra veloce veloce se va bene così già
la bandiera la bandiera veloce veloce
vela tu porca [ __ ] veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce velocissimo
sì sì c'è la bandiera c'è la bandiera
non vi è ragione la bandiera che ci
possa arrivare ci posso arrivare sì sì
sì sì sì sì no no kat
certo la rai a questa è una botta di
cura sturba c'erano lavora anche visto
va bene così cosa devo andare qua sopra
presumo si ok ok calmi
sto uscendo di testa perfetto si sono
gravi
c'è uno quando mi riesce di fare un
qualcosa di fottutamente decente viene
sempre rovinata da delle sorprese
inaspettate sempre maledizione come cosa
devo arrivare dalla gallina cosa devo
fare
non possa arrivare da fare così questa
saresti tua nuova mascotte del
mcdonald's fammi capire cosa devo fare
qui
quella [ __ ]
qualcuno di voi gentilmente mi
spiegherebbe che cosa dovrei fare qui
non lo so sto camminando sono vivo sono
vivo sono io
no no no no no cos'è sono tornati al
menu sono tornati a menu devo riniziato
a capo stiamo scherzando ma sono io che
l'ho comando sono ancora vivo cioè no
raga ma lo sto comandando io sono ancora
vivo se non è
non siamo almeno principessa succede
questo mese impresa inter che i ok no
the game
cos'è sta roba ragazzi cos'è nota gen
cos'è lo vuoi far rifare ma scherziamo
c'è tutto questo si è fumato qualcosa di
pesante
io lui penso anche [ __ ] cos'è cosa
su cos'è dove cazzo siamo ragazzi non
capendo più niente
cioè siamo come siamo arrivati qua raga
non ho capito che cazzo sta succedendo
chesta e di nuovo come prima
mio dio cioè io lo sto rifacendo the
raga io lo sto rifacendo ma sono passato
da un livello all'altro non so come cioè
la cosa no no ok sono perché ora pirlo
non si sa perché va bene
stanno succedendo cose molto strane la
bandiera della terza ok
cioè io mi devo buttare che cosa devo
fare non capito c'è ma se io io muoio
cioè di siamo di nuovo dov'eravamo prima
ok c'è non mi chiedete come ci siamo
arrivati ma siamo di nuovo qui
bene cosa dovrei fare adesso c'è torno
dov'ero prima a che cosa devo fare
adesso devo scendere di nuovo ok ho
chiara che dobbiamo correre stavolta
ricordiamoci che c'era trappola alla
fine se no lo devo rifare un'altra volta
maledizione ce la posso fare by corri
corri malizia si ok adesso devo andare
avanti o stata dall'altra parte ci sono
trappole no perfetto ci dovremmo essere
c'è una spada c'è una squadra nazione
non morire
si no voglio 40
ragazzi è stato un delirio
è finito così sarà meglio pensavo che mi
stesso controllando che devo rifarmi
un'altra volta stavo per commettere un
gatti cibjo però è finito per il meglio
va bene è stata una cosa il professore
questo è il miglior che mario che abbia
mai giocato di sicuro necessito to be
continued quindi ragazzi continuerà
uscire hackett mario cinque per la mia
gioia questo regalo so che conduci
racket mario cinque melo consigliere te
tutti quanti perché sa che in fondo mi
volete molto bene anch'io vi voglio bene
a tutti quanti ma lui no avere gaia
direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio se vi do è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovato nella descrizione
serve siete per iscritti iscrivetevi non
ci rivediamo in un prossimo video bene
ragazzi